what's up ketchup crew welcome to the
weekly ketchup on YouTube where we bring
you guys the biggest news of the week in
movies and TV and this week we explore
the future of the Star Wars franchise
better call saul is gearing up for its
final two seasons and the first Pokemon
movie is getting a CGI remake so here we
go
yes these Skywalker saga may have ended
but Star Wars isn't going anywhere with
more shows movies games and even a game
show on the way so let's break down the
future of the franchise right now on to
catch up there's a lot going on in the
world of Star Wars and thanks to the
Internet some thought that one of those
things was the cancellation of the
upcoming obi-wan kenobe series for
Disney Plus with star Ewan McGregor
leaving due to creative differences but
McGregor's reps later confirmed to the
rat that it's thankfully totally
inaccurate and the show is continuing as
planned so yay we still get more of that
iconic beard and one-liners and so far
no internet rumors have started about
the upcoming rogue one prequel a casseon
and/or spin-off series for Disney Plus
which is also still a go with diego luna
and alan tudyk reprising their roles
from rogue one a prequel to a prequel
double whammy doesn't sound so bad to me
and after the success of the certified
fresh' first season of the mandalorian
there would really be no reason to slow
down on doing more series for the
streaming network especially considering
most people cancelled their Disney Plus
accounts until it comes back this fall
shame on you and speaking of the
Mandalorian and rumors Taika Waititi the
director of the season finale and voice
of the most badass nanny droid ever is
reportedly being courted by Lucasfilm to
direct a Star Wars movie although this
was a Twitter response after the news
broke shout-out to Edgar Wright for the
best comeback
that's an odd photo of Han and Leia I
mean Tyco has been on a serious run with
movies like thor ragnarok
and jojo rabbit along with his work on a
Mandalorian and he does have a couple
films already scheduled in the coming
years including Thor love and thunder
coming in 2021
so attack of Star Wars movie seems a
little far far away right now although I
Tyga directed Star Wars baby movie
starring baby Yoda baby Jabba and Babu
Frick would be really dope
but there are still plenty of other big
names working on Star Wars movies as
well including Marvel Chief Kevin Feige
and last Jedi director Rian Johnson who
confirmed a variety recently that he's
still talking to Lucasfilm but they
haven't announced anything on their
sleep yet as far as what future movies
could look like Disney you seem to hit
the brakes on doing more existing
character spin-offs although that's not
totally off the table either and some of
those characters could come from the
video game world considering shameless
star Cameron Monaghan is featured in the
latest game can I fall in order and some
actually think that the video games will
be kicking off the next big story
spanning into movies and TV one that
takes place four hundred years before
the events of Phantom Menace in a time
known as the High Republic this means a
qui-gon come back there's also a pretty
strong argument to be made for how and
why an episode 10 could work giving some
of the non Skywalker related stories and
characters a chance to evolve check out
our full breakdown of that idea a Tron
tomatoes calm but if you're looking for
something a little less traditional hit
animated series Clone Wars is coming to
Disney Plus in February so time to read
that subscription us all the way back
and the streaming service is also giving
us a game show hosted by charge our
actor Ahmed fest Star Wars Jedi Temple
challenge is aimed at kids and we'll
test young contestants in decor Jedi
principles with fun obstacles so kind of
like legends of the Hidden Temple but
Star Wars there's also the superb Star
Wars rides and experiences at Disneyland
and world's galaxy's edge for fans alike
to be a little more hands-on and drink
blue milk please comment below if you've
been on rise of the resistance and let
us know how it is boot
thank you for joining the calls next
you're gonna call yourself good it's all
good
you're who take a card will last in a
month away from the fifth season
premiere better call Saul which we now
know will set up a six and final season
of the show it's like the beginning of
the end of the beginning so let's take a
look at what we might see in the final
seasons right now on the catch up the
ten episode fifth season of better call
Saul will kick off on AMC with a
two-night premiere on February 23rd and
it's been confirmed that the ensuing
sixth season with 13 episodes will be
the show's last and will go into
production later this year with an
airdate sometime in 2021
it's sad but hey at least we're getting
a few bonus episodes compared to past
season we're just getting started as far
as what we can expect going forward
after witnessing the birth of Saul
Goodman in season four it looks like
we'll get to see him grow into the
fast-talking colorful suit-wearing
character that we know and love from
Breaking Bad does this mean he'll
finally ditch the crappy car and get
that caddie time will tell but hey it's
all good man it's all good man
it's all good but it does mean no doubt
that there will be more Breaking Bad
Easter eggs and characters popping up
confirmed so far is Ed Galbraith played
by the late Robert Forester who also
appeared in the certified fresh' El
Camino Breaking Bad movie and DEA agents
Hank Schrader and Steven Gomez who are
slated to appear in multiple episodes
this season which by the way is a much
better send-off than just being two
pictures on a wall during this teaser
for El Camino that didn't even make it
in the movie and in a new promo video
from AMC it was confirmed that stories
like Jimmy's transformation the volatile
cartel and a new bad guy Lalo Salamanca
and even the journey of Kim Wexler will
start to overlap but will there be more
death and destruction from the twins you
can only hope amigos
and speaking of Kim Wexler these final
seasons will most likely show the end of
her relationship with Jimmy and more
importantly reveal the reason why we
never see or hear of her in Breaking Bad
and now that the show is finally moved
into the era of Walter White as
evidenced by a construction beginning on
Gus's epic underground meth lab the big
question fans want to know is if and
when we will see Walt or Jesse Pinkman
after all jesse did introduce Walt -
Saul - great for a letter names you
don't want a criminal lawyer you want a
criminal lawyer well we know that Brian
Cranston is pretty much down for
anything and series creator Vince
Gilligan did say a comic on a couple
years ago that he would quote be sorely
remiss if these characters didn't appear
on the show before ended but Aaron Paul
has said in multiple interviews recently
that he felt like El Camino was the
proper send-off for his character which
I say come on Captain Cook now if you
are trying to catch up or need a
refresher there's good news because
season four of better call saw hits
Netflix on February 9th so mark those
Cullen videos and if you are already
excited about season 5 Bob Odenkirk told
deadline a while back that it is the
best season we've ever done it's gonna
blow your mind and I'm not kidding about
either of those things it's awesome okay
well no need to call Saul for that one
there's no way to prove anything
all right friends it's time to kick it
over to you now what do you think will
happen in the final seasons of better
call Saul will it end mere moments
before he meets Walt for the first time
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and remember the conversation
will continue in our fan Facebook groups
and be sure to check that out
[Music]
put down your Pokemon go because the
first-ever Pokemon movie is getting a
complete CGI makeover in a new remake
but will it outperform the original on
the tomato meter let's talk about it
right now on the ketchup it's been over
20 years since Pokemon the first movie
in Mewtwo strikes back hit theaters and
despite a global box office total of
over a hundred and sixty three million
dollars and an audience score of 63
percent the film is just 15 percent on
the tomato meter the overall consensus
is that audiences other than children
will find very little to entertain them
and over the years critics have called
it things like 70 minutes of irritation
a shameless plug for Pokemon merchandise
and sadly lacking heart
um did they not see the scene where
Pikachu cries ash back to life I mean it
was basically Shakespeare
the new remake called pokémon the movie
Mewtwo strikes back evolution will hit
Netflix on February 27th which of course
is Pokemon Day hey Google set a reminder
as in your directory creation of its
predecessor and with the original
director returning the story will feel
familiar to longtime fans but instead of
the hand-drawn look of anime from the
first and 20 ensuing animated films this
one features all the latest CG
technology so it's basically like the
same thing that happened to Spongebob
and since the film already debuted in
Japan last July there is currently one
review on Rotten Tomatoes giving it a
rotten rating
it's from IGN's miranda Sanchez who said
the new animation style makes action
scenes more flashy but its story starts
to drag about halfway through and never
quite recovers time will tell if that is
a bad sign or not so keep checking our T
in the coming weeks for a tomato meter
updates and let us know what your
audience review would be but fans have
been reacting to the new trailer on
social media with many like Brandon on
Facebook saying there's no need to
remake the film the original was perfect
CGI looks dreadful I mean it's no cats
but I feel yeah with others like Manny
saying I'll gladly watch this I would
love to see other 90s 2000s ideas
brought back 90s nostalgia is in let's
just never bring back cargo shorts
though ok ok I'm
for and it's that nostalgic factor that
could help this new remake become a hit
I mean the kids who saw and loved the
first one in theaters are now the ones
who will be reviewing it which could
lead to a more positive score and don't
forget that the success of 2019 is
detective Pikachu a live-action movie
featuring the voice of Ryan Reynolds
that is a fresh 69 percent on the tomato
meter and made 431 million worldwide so
throw in the ongoing popularity of the
Pokemon games like sword and shield for
Nintendo switch and the brand is strong
which means now it's a great time for
Netflix to try and cash in on some
Pokemon a did that land alright guys I
want to kick it over to you now are you
excited for the CGI remake of Pokemon
the first movie also what is your
favorite pokémon squirtle is mine let us
know in the comments section and guess
what we have a Facebook group now so
let's continue this conversation in our
new catch up fan group also for more
movie news check out Rotten Tomatoes
calm and don't forget to vote in our
golden tomato award fan categories while
you're there it is your civic duty
alright friends thanks for tuning into
the weekly ketchup on youtube be sure to
tap that subscribe button and
notification bell so you don't miss any
future episodes of the show as always
I'm Nass Prez and we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]